Can you explain the significance of the
coin in the fish mouse which uh Jesus
picked up to pay um the
>> Matthew 17 427?
>> Yeah. I I I just wondered why the coin
in the fish mouse. What's the
significance?
>> Significant. I love you, brother.
Peter's a fisherman.
>> Yeah, that's
>> Yeah, that's that's what
>> Peter's a fisherman, right?
>> Yeah.
>> He's referring to this Matthew 17:24-27.
when they now when they came to
Capernaum those who collected the two
drama tax came to Peter and said does
your teacher not pay the two drama tax?
Now according to our Bible Jesus is who?
>> Uh the son of Yahweh.
>> Okay. And so if he's a son of the
father, is he also Yahweh or no?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. And who owns the temple?
>> Yahweh himself. It's his own. So is
Jesus Yahweh?
>> Yes.
>> And he owns the temple, right?
>> Yeah.
>> And yet they're demanding of the owner
temple to pay tax to the temple that he
owns.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Do you understand now the point or
No, let me because I want you to unpack
it. Now notice they're demanding of
Jesus. Every Jew is obligated to pay the
temple tax. So you're a Jew. Do you
think you're exempt from it? Yeah.
Because I own the temple. You're paying
me. but you don't recognize who I am.
So, this is the irony. What's the irony?
The irony is they're asking the God at
the temple who's now appearing in the
flesh to pay taxes to the temple he owns
when the taxes are for him. Right.
>> Yeah. Okay. That's Yeah.
>> That's why he says to Peter the
following. He said, "Yes." When he came
in the house, Jesus spoke to him first,
saying, "What do you think, Simon? From
whom do the kings of the year collect
tolls or taxes? From their sons or from
strangers?" In other words, if I'm the
son of God and I'm the heir of God and
this is my father's house, then it's my
house, right?
>> Yeah.
>> The father take taxes from his own son.
>> No, not if he's
>> yet. These idiots want me to pay tax to
the house that I own because I'm the
heir.
>> But they don't recognize him as the
>> Yeah, they don't recognize him. But
another thing you probably didn't catch.
Notice
Peter wasn't with Jesus outside when
they asked Peter, "Do you teacher does
your teacher pay the drama tax?" But
Jesus already knew what they asked him
because he spoke first before Peter told
him why he was there.
>> Yeah. Because he's omnicient.
>> Okay, caught it now. The divinity of
Christ. Peter was coming to tell him,
"Lord, they want us to pay the dogma
tax." Before Simon said a word, Jesus
already knew what he came for. Do you
see it?
>> Yeah.
>> When he entered, Jesus spoke to him
first. How did Jesus know what Simon was
coming to ask?
>> The same way he knew about uh the one
brother who sat under the tree which
convinced them that Jesus is God. or he
knew what they're thinking in their
hearts that is saying he was blaspheing.
Okay, so now notice Jesus is unveiling
his divine identity. All right, now look
how deep it goes.
Simon, from whom do the kings of the
earth collect tolls or taxes? From their
sons or from strangers? When Peter said
from strangers, you said to him, then
the sons are exempt. So if you're a son,
you don't pay taxes, right?
>> Yeah. For free. Can
>> lest I cause them offense. Because if I
don't pay the tax, they're going to
think I'm a lawb breaker, that I'm
sinning against God cuz I'm breaking the
law. Even though I'm the God who gave
the law and I'm the God who owns the
temple. Nonetheless, they don't know who
I am. However, so that we do not offend
them. Go to the sea and throw in a hook
and take the first fish that comes up.
When he opens mouth, you'll find the
stater. Take that and give it to them
for me and you. Now, notice Peter's a
fisherman, right?
>> Yeah. So what the Lord is saying is not
only am I aware that the first fish you
catch and by the way till this day in
this area of Capernum
there are fish that you'll find with
stuff in their mouth. That's why they're
called St. Peter's fish.
If you Google against
>> what? Go ahead.
>> They like littering stuff and
>> Yes. Like you find corks and coins in
their mouth to this day. It's they're
called St. Peter's fish. When people
fish in this area, they find fish with
things caught in their mouth, debris.
It's called St. Peter's fish.
Guys, confirm and Google it so you don't
think I'm lying. So, the Lord is not
only showing that he's even aware of
marine life, he's not just aware of what
humans do. He's fully aware
of everything that takes place in
creation because he even oversees
preserves marine life. He's the one
sustaining the sea. He's the one
sustaining the life in the sea. He's the
one sustaining the fish in the sea. He's
the one sustain sustaining marine life.
So, he's aware of what all the fish and
the sea animals do in the sea because
he's sustaining them. And he's aware
that fish that he's going to catch has
the coin.
It shows his sovereignty over all
creation. But it also shows the third
element. You know what the third element
is?
>> Uh I just wondering about his age
because Peter and Jesus had only to pay
and the others are younger so they can
free.
>> No, it's not that. That's not the point.
It's just saying that Jesus is going to
pay for Simon Peter and him because they
asked Peter about his master. So he's
saying, "Okay, I'm going to do you a
salad. I'm going to pay for you and me."
But no, no, no. What's the third thing
you learn?
You guys confirmed, right, Gary? Yep.
Mango tilapia. I don't know how you
pronounce it. Tilapia. That's the fish.
It's called St. Peter's fish.
Go check it out. All right. Now the
third thing you learn, not only is God
aware that the fish contains a coin to
pay his taxes and Peter, but it shine to
show you that even animals recognize who
their creator is and pay him tribute and
that they're willing to pay his taxes.
>> Yeah.
>> You understand the irony here?
The irony is
>> the animals obey but humans who are much
more smarter don't.
>> Exactly. My creatures, even the marine
life recognize who I am, their creator.
And in recognition of who I am, they go
out of the way to pay me tribute, show
me honor, and they're willing to pay my
taxes for me. And yet, human beings
don't recognize who I am as I stand
before them.
>> Yeah. See the the irony here? It's
similar to Jonah and the whale. When God
told Jonah to go to Nineveh, he ran. But
when he commanded the whale to swallow
Jonah, immediately it obeyed. And when
God commanded the whale to vomit Jonah,
immediately it obeyed, showing that even
a a marine animal shows more
faithfulness, common sense, and
obedience, and fear of God than Jonah.
Because when God commanded that marine
animal to swallow Jonah, he did without
hesitation. And when that marine animal
was told to vomit Jonah, he did without
hesitation. And yet Jonah is supposed to
be smarter than an animal is so stupid
enough that he thinks he can disobey God
and run away from him.
The book of Jonah, right? Same
principle. So here's the Lord showing
right that even marine life, even
animals know who I am. They know I'm the
creator, the sustainer. And they know
enough to then honor me as such and
revere me as such to the extent that a
fish will go out of its way to pay
tribute to me and honor me by paying my
taxes.
Even the waves and the wind recognize
who I am. Because when I told the winds,
"Be still." It obeyed me and went
silent.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. Remember when they were they
thought they were going to drown and
Jesus says, "Quiet. Be still." And
immediately the waves and the wind died
down.
>> Yeah.
>> Because what's that supposed to show?
All creation with the exception of
humans recognize Jesus that he's their
God, sustainer
and preserver. Whereas humans who are
supposedly smarter than inanimate
objects, smarter than animals, failed to
recognize the glory of Jesus. Here it
is. That's why they were shocked. Mark 4
35-41
right here. And on that day when evening
came, he said to them, "Let us go over
to the other side." And leaving, this is
also in Matthew 8, but I wanted to use
the Mark version. Uh, excuse me. Leaving
the crowd, they took him along with them
in the boat just as he was. and the
other boats were with him. And a great
windstorm arose and the waves were
breaking into the boat so that the boat
was already filling up. And Jesus
himself was in the stern sleeping on the
cushion. They got up. They got him up
and said to him, "Teacher, do you not
care that we are perishing?" He re he
woke up and rebuked the wind and said to
the sea, "Silence, be still." The same
words he said to the demoniac in Mark 1,
"Be still. Come out of him." and the
wind died down and became perfectly
calm. So even the winds and the waves
recognized the voice of the creator and
obeyed him immediately in the presence
of disciples which caused them to freak
out because look what they say. And he
and he said to them, "Why are you so
cowardly? Do you still have no faith?"
And they became very afraid and were
saying to one another, "Who then is this
that even the wind of the sea obey him?"
So there you go. You got one more
question, brother. Let's answer that
final one for now and you can come back
when I do another Q&A.
>> Uh, I can come back later. It's quite
enough for this. Yeah, I need to wrap my
head around the next ones.
>> Good. Then wrap around and come back.
Maybe some tomorrow I'll do another Q&A.
You can come and ask me, brother.
>> Okay. Thank you.
>> Lord bless. God bless you, too.
Superb questions.